The fire department presentations. Reminder to council members you
should submit any department budget workshop questions in a word
document and upload it to SharePoint budget
workspace. Departments have been directed to provide responses within 48
hours of the conclusion of their presentations. Department responses
will also be uploaded to SharePoint. We will now hear from Chief Pena,
who will provide the fire Department budget. Chief floor is yours.
Thank you, Mr. Vice Chair. First of all, I want to thank you.
I want to thank the committee members for allowing me to present the
Houston Fire Department's proposed fiscal year 2023 budget.
Before I begin, I'd like to acknowledge some of my civilian staff
and of course, my command staff for the
assistance that they provided in preparing this budget. With me.
I have the Houston Fire Department's department fiscal
administrator, Ms. Rochelle McHenry. I also have members of
my command staff here. Chief west and Chief McLeod are
joining us. But the
thanks goes to all our staff who really have been
doing tremendous work. I also want to acknowledge and thank Mayor Turner and this
council for giving me the support this year and the finances to
provide the needs for this organization.
The Houston Fire Department is the third largest municipal
fire department, protecting the fourth largest city in the country.
And my hat goes off to the men and women of the Houston
Fire Department for the incredible work that they do each and every day.
It's an active system, just like any major city. We run about 344,000
calls for service each year. We're still dealing with
the effects of the pandemic and working
through some very challenging times. But I cannot say enough about the work that the
men and women of the Houston Fire Department do to ensure the safety of
this community. So very proud of the work that they do.
First slide, please.
So the proposed fiscal year 2023 budget for the
Houston Fire Department is $559,000,000.
This will be funding 3933.3
FTEs in six funds. The distribution of the funds and
the personnel are displayed here in six key areas.
And as you can see, the major funding is for personnel
that is allocated to the emergency response program. Next slide.
Our primary function and mission is the protection of lives and property
of our residents. Our goal is to accomplish this primarily through
prevention, code enforcement and investigations. But we do
spend a lot of money to train and prepare for responses to
emergency medical calls, fire calls,
hazmat, technical rescue, aircraft rescue, and a variety
of other programs. Next slide.
The legal provisions that guide our agency and approve
programs and services for our department are listed here on this slide.
I do want to highlight the last bullet point in the anticipation of
increased demand in service for our department. This is
particularly going to be in the area of emergency medical services.
The population growth, and especially the aging population will
drive up the need for our services. The same thing will occur
with the aging infrastructure as it relates to fire response.
So it is critical, and it's more important now more than ever
that we maintain focus of adopting appropriate
fire codes and enforcement tools to maintain the desired quality of life
here in the city. Next slide, please.
So, as we move on to the financials of our presentation, this first slide
summarizes the department's revenue projections for the general fund.
In fiscal year 23, we're projecting a slight increase in the majority
of our regular operating revenue streams. This is going to
be offset by a larger decrease in three specific
revenue accounts. So the overall net effect for
our revenues is a decrease of 7.73%,
or $8.9 million, from fiscal year 22 to fiscal
year 23. For our department, the revenue
is derived primarily from licensings and permits intergovernmental
revenue. This is in addition to
charges for services or ambulance transports.
Direct inner funds. This is the money that we receive from Haas for personnel
assigned to the airport stations. The miscellaneous
item, the category, is primarily the reimbursement
for our special operations teams and their deployments.
So licenses and permits are essentially flat.
This year is our projection with a slight increase in the expected fire permit
revenue. We're also projecting a 39%
reduction in the intergovernmental category due to
an increase primarily to the amount of money we're going to receive
from the ambulance supplemental payment program. And I'll explain more
in a later slide. The charges for service increase
is primarily due to the expected increase in Hazmat permits, which will bring us
back to the pre pandemic revenue figures. This is going to be offset
against a decrease in cell phone revenue towers.
This is the lease money that we get from Verizon for allowing
them to put their cell towers on the fire stations.
In the direct interfund services, this is the chargeback
for Haas. Again, for airport firefighters, the change reflects
a 6% base pay raise offset against
a lower pension rate for this account,
for other fines and forfeits the amount from fiscal year
22 is essentially flat. In the miscellaneous
and other categories, the change from budget to estimate is
a decrease of ten point 43%.
This is going to be primarily due to an expected decrease in the natural disaster
reimbursement. Again, for for deployments in fiscal year 21 and 22,
the tactical deployment of the Texas Task Force
One members. They were deployed higher than normal,
and we don't expect the same number of deployments this fiscal year.
In other resources, we captured the revenue associated with the Enterprise
Light duty lease program for our light duty vehicles,
and I have a slide that will go more in depth a little bit
later. So again, the fiscal year 23 projection
revenue of $107.4 million is approximately 7.73%
less than fiscal year 2022s.
Again, I want to stress the point that this is mainly due to the ambulance
supplemental payment program which will be reduced, and I'll explain more
on this. Next slide, please.
So, as mentioned, the supplemental reimbursement program is
expected to drop by about $9.5 million.
This fund provides for the reimbursement for care, for Medicaid
and indigent care patients. So as of October 1,
2019, the uncompensated care program transitioned
to a charity care pool. This change eliminated
the Medicaid shortfall supplemental program, and it
redefined it as an uninsured cost to charity care
cost. Okay. That's the significant change.
This required agencies to have
a charity care policy in place. The first year,
very few providers were able to get that policy in place.
The Houston Fire Department. The City of Houston actually did. So we were one
of the few participants in the pool. This second year,
more providers are able to have that policy in place.
So we have more agencies competing with the same
pool. So the number of dollars in the
pool did not increase, but the number of participants did. So the
disbursement was a little less to every provider.
That's essentially the high level explanation on why we're getting a lower return
this year. Next slide, please.
Okay. This is the Vehicle
Lease program. So this program has allowed us to do a
wholesale replacement of our vehicles, the light duty vehicles,
primarily in the Life Safety Bureau, and we
are in the first replacement cycle for that
program. The program we incorporated
105 vehicles in the lease program this
year. We were supposed to sell that one year old
vehicle, 105 of them, and get new vehicles.
The money that was realized from that sale was going to go back
reprogrammed into the program. Because of supply chain issues,
we were only able to sell 49 vehicles.
So, as you can see, the disbursement was
$563,000 for those
vehicles. Enterprise what they did is they gave us
65% of the equity in those
vehicles. They paid it out this year for next fiscal
year, we will sell again those 49 one year old vehicles,
plus 56 vehicles that now will be two years old.
And we'll realize only the 35% equity that was left over.
That's the reason for the change
in the revenue. But essentially, as you
can see, the first year we realized, to the
benefit of the city is $391,000.
We replaced 105 vehicles. The program really,
it was essentially cost neutral. Matter of fact,
the city was reimbursed an additional 395 or $91,000
fiscal year 23. Our projection is going to be about half
of that. Again, because of the explanation that I gave earlier, we're selling two euro
vehicles instead of €1 vehicles. After this year,
we will be back on track to sell,
replace 105, and sell 105 every year.
Next slide.
These are expenditures by funds. The proposed expenditure
target for fiscal year 23 is $559,000,000,
which represents an increase of 20.3 million
from the current budget of $538.7
million. The increase by category
and personnel cost is a net of several increases including civilian and
classified base and related fringes, as well as classified overtime
and classified health. This will be offset against a decrease in the classified
pension and classified workers comp cost.
A 10.9% increase in supplies is due to an increase
in cost of doing business, primarily in
drugs, medical surgical supplies, as well as a small increase
for the GL account for the fifth Academy class
that we were approved for this coming fiscal year.
Contributing to the overall 3.77% growth is an increase
in our restricted accounts of eleven point 61%.
This is the Interfund chargeback accounts for It
for HR, fuel and fleet services.
And lastly, an increase in our service account of $958,000
is a transfer of funds from GST for the payment of our
lease for our building, for our headquarters.
This is in addition to that, it's an increase in other inner
fund services for payments of It service personnel.
Contractual increases which will be offset again by a decreasing
in billing and collection expenditure from our medical
biller because of the reduced amount in the ASPP
fund, the ambulance supplemental plan. The equipment
fund change is due to not requiring us to invest
this year for items that were purchased in fiscal year 21 and 22.
In 21 we purchased some surface pro tablets,
some related equipment, some desktops and three thermal imagers.
In fiscal year 22, those expenditures were directed
towards extrication equipment, jobs of life and those types
of equipment. We will not have to make that purchase this year. That's the reason
for the change. As far
as the explanation for the Debt services fund, in fiscal year
21, $53,000 was transferred from Fund 1000 to
Fund 40 515. This was done for the purchase of
drone equipment for our tactical deployment team.
We ran out of time actually to get that purchase done before
the end of the fiscal year. So we did receive approval to transfer
the funds that were allocated from District G's service
funds to Fund 40 515.
That way we wouldn't lose that budget. That's the explanation for that.
Next slide please. So this is how our funds
are allocated. Of the fiscal year 23 budget,
88% is allocated to Personnel services.
This leaves a total operating budget of $69.5 million,
of which 63% or
45 point or $43.5 million is in
restricted accounts. This is for HR.
Interfunds fleet interfunds and so on.
17% is in the other category. This is for
certain contracts, our telemetry contract and other service contracts.
6% is allocated for our billing and collections agency,
which leaves us approximately $10.2 million annually
to cover medical supplies, to cover personal protective equipment,
firefighting equipment and other supplies needed for the operation of this
organization. Next slide please.
So this slide walks us through the changes from fiscal year 22 current
budget to fiscal year 2023 proposed budget. Our fiscal
year 22 current budget is $538.7 million,
of which 36.8 million is in restricted accounts.
The 22 current budget figure of 538
is a net adjustment for fiscal year 22.
Hope contractual adjustments. It includes restricted accounts increases
of $2.2 million, some health benefit returns
of $3.8 million, and a city council surplus
dollars of $29,000. Other operating contractual
adjustments of 4.7 million includes one time adjustments for
workers compensation increases, overtime expenditures,
which are then offset by classified and cadet vacancy savings.
So the total adjustment, the one time adjustment for this is $3.3
million. So to go from 22 to
23 budget, we have incremental increases and decreases in operating
and contractually mandated expenses.
And I'll explain here. So coming back into the budget
is $2.75 million for our fifth academy
class that was approved funding for a 6% across
the board pay raise for classified personnel, other classified adjustments
of $2.4 million for base overtime,
a return of the council surplus dollars, and a reversal of
the one time operating adjustments for a total of three. I'm sorry.
$21.3 million in adjustments or a 4.26
increase from FY 22 to FY
23. The contractual
obligations include the following hope obligations
contractual obligations adjustments for civilian and
classified health, civilian and classified pension and FICA and
other funding or restricted accounts, contract, Escalations,
and other contractual adjustments. So the subtotal of contractual
obligations is -920 $6,000,
which is largely the result of savings related to the reduction in the
classified pension rate, the operating
contractual obligation adjustments of $20.3 million, which takes
us to our fiscal year 23 proposed budget of $559,000,000,
or a 3.77% increase from 20. Two's current budget.
Next slide, please. So,
these are the highlights of the materials we just covered. Of additional
focus, I'd like to mention the five non certified
cadet training classes for a total of 350 new
hires for fiscal year 23, and the cost associated
for the continuation of three non certified classes,
which were begun this fiscal year.
In addition to that is a grant match for the AFG grant to provide
training and physicals with cancer screenings for firefighters
and also the completion of our vehicle exhaust installation.
That grant matches approximately $309,000.
And then
we discussed the other ones already. So next slide, please.
That is my presentation vice Chair. I am open for any
questions. Thank you, Chief, for your presentation, I'm going to start with questions from
Council member Abby Cayman. Thank you so much, Vice Chair.
Chief, thank you for not only to you, to your
executive team command all the way on down. It's a privilege
to work with you all. Thank you. Few quick questions. As I said, I'm asking
this of every department. Given the budgetary
and financial constraints that the city continues to face due
to revenue limitations,
what can we not afford right now
that's needed? That's not to say that mayor and council
is not trying to approve everything that we can, but there are significant large
budget items that are necessary that we, quite frankly, can't afford.
Such as I'll say it, and I know council Member Peck will probably raise it.
CAD I'm looking back in the appendix
diesel exhaust removal for some of our stations.
Are there other things that we
need to be talking about
that we cannot necessarily afford right now?
Council Member the answer to that question is definitely a
yes. You mentioned technology is a critical
need for our organization. The computer aided dispatcher
CAD system needs complete replacement on that.
We're working with almost a 20 year old system, and there are a
lot of things that we could be doing to create efficiencies within the organization
that are not possible because of the age of that program.
One of them is dispatching by location,
vehicle location, text to 911.
All those priority dispatch systems, all those
things that we can explore are a little bit more difficult
because of the age of that system. So technology is one of them.
The other needs are going to be primarily focused on training and
professional development for the members of the organization.
An increase in service capacity,
primarily ambulance and transport service capacity is
what we need, and there are a lot of needs for
upgrades in our facilities.
I need you to put me back in queue. I had one more question.
You have one more. Go ahead. Okay, thank you. And again, Chief, I do want
to congratulate you on in the department on the things you have accomplished.
Again, going back to the appendix, the increase
in pay, the Hazmat units,
the following up on 100%
of cardiac arrest incidents, adoption of the fire code,
the lease vehicle program. There's a
lot in here that is absolutely to be commended
for. I do want to point out I continue when we look at the
comparative gender and ethnicity statistics,
the very low level in terms of classified of
female employees. Yes. And that's it, I think
3.85% compared to 96.15%
in the largest population of
HFD employees. So I would just bring our attention to that. In terms
of recruitment, I know that there are recruitment challenges that we continue to face,
but I know that we are striving to be as diverse
as possible, and I see that reflected in Y'all's efforts.
But I just wanted to point that out that we have more work
to do there. And if you could really quickly touch base on you
kind of touched on it, but our inspection capacity and
our ambulance transport capacity I know you just mentioned
it, but inspection capacity seems to be a
pretty big need. Yes, ma'am.
Look, if we focus all our attention and resources
on just the emergency response, we're never going to be able to keep up with
demand. We're going to make the biggest impact in
our call volume and demand if we prevent things
from happening. That speaks to
our need to provide more inspections for
these commercial businesses. Having more inspectors to ensure that
the codes, when we're building, we're building appropriately and
up to code and having those eyes on scene to ensure
that we are meeting those codes because it's going to assist us downstream
in not having to respond to so many fires or major fires.
The same thing goes for medical response.
25% of our basic life support calls
are people that call more than once or twice per
year. Okay? And what we found is that those individuals
don't need the most expensive taxi to go to the most expensive
part of the Er. They need access to the right social service. Right. We have
that information. It's having resources to
focus on those social services and making
those connections with existing agencies that's going to allow us
to make a definite impact on the number of calls that
come in from repeat customers. Let me say it that way.
So certainly inspectors and then we know
that we have an increase in population and increase in aging population
and whether we like it or not, we are the medical safety
net for this community. So emergency medical transport
and ambulance service is what we need to focus on right now.
We're limited in our ability to increase that because of our
staffing situation. But strategically that's something
that we've discussed with the mayor and administration.
The mayor is completely supportive of doing that.
We just need to fix the staffing
issue first and then we can move forward.
Chief, when looking at your presentation,
can correct me if I'm wrong, but it seems that you had an
increase in expenditures but a decrease in revenues.
Yes. What creative ways can we increase revenues
within the department? Other ways to increase revenues in the department of
course. Look, the major revenue
source is our charge for service and primarily
ambulance service.
We brought forth a recommendation for an ordinance,
an increase in the charge a couple of years ago.
That recommendation was based on data that was
already a couple of years old at that time.
Since then we've had an increase of
6% pay raise last year. We are
going to have a 6% increase this coming year. And so
the cost of delivering service has gone up not only in personnel
cost but also the cost of supplies and materials.
In one particular drug that we use the
cost went up almost 90%. Right. And so everything
is going up. We are not
recovering what it cost us to deliver. So we need to another analysis,
another study to see what that rate would be. Second thing
is our payer mix is heavy medicare,
Medicaid in this community. And then we have a
large percentage of self pay which means no
insurance. So our collection rate is about 39%
to 40%.
At some point medicare or Medicaid is expanded.
We would have the ability to collect
more. Increasing the rate of
service cost or the charge
for service would be one way because medicare and Medicaid they
reimbursed at the usual and customary rate. We are
the big elephant in the room.
We are the largest ambulance provider in this region,
so if we keep our rates arbitrarily low,
there is no incentive for that reimbursement
for Medicare, Medicaid to be adjusted upward. So we have
to look at some of these things. I know it's a difficult conversation,
but again, the that is our
primary service provide or service
that we provide, where we get reimbursement from when
looking at other large cities around the country, how are we as it
relates to competitive salaries?
Well, look, all I can base it on is what we provide,
what we presented a year ago.
And that was based on a total comp study for
pay. And we were below the average, about 18%.
The mayor and council approved us to increase the
pay rate by 18% to try to help us get up to at
least the median. But every year,
the new contracts in other areas go up. There is incentives
and pay increases that happen. And so we
have to have a strategy to be
competitive. Council member Amy
Pitt. Thank you. And thank you, Chief, for the presentation.
You talked about equipment purchased last year
that we don't have to purchase this year, and that's why that line item
went down. Can you talk a little bit about what's in the budget
for just regular equipment, like normal wear and tear, aging equipment,
also equipment that's stolen, like it was just stolen on engine
four the other day, that kind of thing? Yes.
I want to say it's unfortunate, but shrinkage is something that we experience as
well here in the department several times.
That was the most recent one. But we do experience
theft oftentimes. A lot of times it's our employees
who are the victims of that. At the fire stations, they have
their vehicles broken into. We do have monies
allocated council members for the MNO of our equipment.
Every year we try to anticipate a certain number of replacement.
We've taken a different approach in the last five years, starting from the big
ticket items like our apparatus.
We've gotten to the point where we are almost
on schedule to replace every one of our apparatus every ten years.
And so again, council and
mayor, you all have made a significant investment in allowing us
to get that plan implemented. But we've taken
the same approach for everything in our inventory.
Everything has a shelf life. Everything has a total life
expectancy. It needs to be replaced. It's easier to replace and take
small bites at the apple every year than to wait until we have
to make wholesale replacements. It's very hard to budget
that way. So to answer your question is yes, we do have
a replacement plan for every one of our items
that we have in our inventory. Great.
Thank you. The Vehicle Lease program.
I love this program. Are we planning on expanding that past the
105 vehicles? Yes. The answer is yes.
Our hope is that we're going to include all the arson vehicles and eventually
all the light duty vehicles. We're also looking,
and I'm working with staff to see if we can lease
the heavy apparatus for those stations that are slowest
in call volume. So the
plan is to take those apparatus,
take them off the board on the replacement plan, and put them into a lease
program until we can make some significant improvements
on the existing on the remaining ones, and then put them back
into slowly fold them back into the replacement plan.
One of the latest projections was
that I can get ten vehicles for a million
dollars a year on a lease, ten apparatus.
And it would mean moving from CIP
funding to operating funds. But I think that's a
I mean, that's a proper use of government funds of city
resources because it allows us to have one serviceable
equipment and two at a lower cost per
year. And so, yes, I'd like to
expand it. The program that we have in place now,
I think the proof of concept is that it works.
As I mentioned, at worst, we break even. But we
have brand new vehicles, one year old vehicles every year.
And that not only increases our efficiencies, but it improves morale.
We were running around with 1520 year old vehicles.
A lot of them didn't even have the latest safety equipment.
So this is a good program. I think
it's good government. I think it's a responsible way of using city
resources, and I'm hoping to expand this program. Great. Thank you,
chief and vice chair. If you could put me back in the queue of another
question. Thank you. Go ahead.
My last question is, is there anything that we should
be funding for insurance or accreditation reasons that
we are not funding in this proposed budget?
Okay, I'm not understanding your question. I know that there are
certain things that we're supposed to like programs, numbers,
that kind of thing that we're supposed to be doing every year. Is there something
in the unmet needs that we should be doing? I mean, I know that everything
is a need, but something that we could lose some kind of accreditation
or insurance purposes that we should be funding that we're
not? Well, look, we just got
our ISO rating for the city of Houston and the Houston Fire Department.
It came back as an ISO one, which is the highest level you
can get. We just received our accreditation from the Commission on Fire Accreditation
International.
We've met the requirements for those. But we do have
to be looking at the increase in call volume
and what we're going to do about that. One of the things that we need
is additional transport units. And I've mentioned this before, not only
in this budget presentation, but in other committee presentations. We need
more ambulances. Our response times for
those call volume or those call types is going to increase.
I don't know that we're at risk of losing any certification
or accreditation for that. But we certainly at some
point, if we don't make a strategic effort to
address that, we won't be meeting the needs that the
community is expecting. And so increasing ambulance
capacity is one of the main things that we need to be
looking at inspections is another one.
We need more inspectors.
Again, the biggest impact we're going to make is in the prevention
side, not on the response side. So to do that, we need inspectors.
We'll now move into the public comment period of the
hearing. We have three virtual public speakers,
and the first one is Saba Blanding. Please press
star six to unmute. Saba Blanding.
Okay, yeah, you think I have this down
by now, but still a struggle.
Chief, you really actually already answered my first question,
but I'm going to ask it in case you wanted to expand.
And that was what do you need in order to better provide preventative services?
You mentioned increasing inspectors, and I was also curious in
regards to that, if it's primarily an issue of staffing
or training or both, and if there was any other needs you
all had. And then along with that, I'm curious,
what preventative measures do you think the city could take beyond what it
currently exists to reduce the demand on your department on
the response side? And I really appreciate you bringing up the importance of
prevention. So that's my primary question. Thank you.
Okay, so in regards to the inspectors question,
it's both It's personnel and It's. Training in
order to do fire inspections. The Texas Commission on Fire Protection requires
a certification as a state inspector, and so that takes
a little while to train
people up, but first we need personnel.
It's a combination of both.
In regards to what would help in
stemming the increased call volume. I think the
more a concerted effort in
a public safety message on the proper use of 911,
we have a lot of calls that don't
qualify as emergencies,
but people still use the 911
system for things that really could be handled
in a different way. So I think we
have some work to do in providing information,
providing a
better way of communicating how to properly
use the 911 system because it's a busy system. As I mentioned, we run
close to 350,000 calls for service every year,
and that's just us. The 911 center receives
a couple of million calls. I'm not exactly sure what the number
is, but for both police and fire at the 911 center,
and a
certain percentage of those calls wouldn't really qualify
as emergency, but we still have to respond to them, and so
that would be one way to do that.
Thank you. Our next virtual speaker is Mr. Jason Oliver.
Please press star six to unmute.
Hi, Chief. I wanted
to follow up on something you mentioned about pay. You said that
the 18% will bring. US up to the average
from last year. Right.
So any raises that departments or comparison
departments have made last year or this year
or next year. Right. When we get to the 18%,
they'll be at 25 or 30%.
Well, maybe not that far, but they'll be significantly beyond
whatever we end up at. Is that correct?
I do know, Mr. Oliver, that the city of Houston
is commissioning a comp study for this year. It should be
ready sometime this year, and we'll have a
better target of where we stand in comparison to
our counterparts in our industry.
The 18% was much needed,
and it's a huge step in the right direction. I will wait
for the comp study to come up sometime this
year, and then we will make the case for additional pay raises
for our firefighters. But, look, it's retention and
recruitment is a practical concern for me.
We have to be competitive in our industry to maintain
the talent that we have here on the department. It costs us a
lot of money to train and recruit, and we want them to remain
on this department. So one way to do that is to ensure
that we're competitive in pay. And then one last
question about I know the emergency center
has come up kind of talking about how they're facing issues with
pay, and the non emergency
number response is a bit slow. Is that
contributing to what you're seeing in terms of the
kind of oversaturation of 911 and fire calls
that you're responding to that aren't actual emergencies?
Yes. So the 911 center employs civilian call
takers. The initial call goes to that
area. Those are civilians. And then, depending on the
needs of the caller, whether it's fire medical,
then it goes to the fire department. Any law enforcement need
goes to the police department. From there, our dispatchers the
second level once it gets past the call taker for the fire department
are classified personnel, and we are fully
staffed in that area.
But again,
it's more of a training, and we have to do a better
job. We, the emergency services, need to do a better job of
communicating and an educational approach
for our community on the proper use of the 911
system, what's an emergency, what would not be considered an emergency, and then provide
them the resources on how else they can get their needs
addressed without necessarily calling 911. So it's
a more comprehensive approach to
that question. Thank you.
Our next virtual speaker is Mr. Doug Smith.
Can you hear me? Yes.
Great. You just said you
received the top ratings from the two rating agencies, and I've heard in the past
that the fire department is understaffed
and you could use a lot more people. And I'm wondering
if there's a concern that you could possibly lose those ratings
if you don't get the people you need. That's one question.
The second question on page
three, four of your report. It's the statistics,
performance measures. You don't have any response times
for first unit call response times for
either EMS or fire, and I'm wondering why that
is. And also on that page, you talk about EMS
incidents and responses and fire incidents
and responses, and the responses are a lot higher
than the incidents, and I'm curious what the differentiation
is between those two.
Okay, Mr. Smith, you're going to have to repeat the second part of
your question, the first one in regards to staffing,
look, I've made several presentations to the Public Safety
Committee. I made the same presentation
last year regarding when we presented
our budget regarding staffing in 2019 and 2020,
we missed our recruitment target by about 280 firefighters.
That was as a result of Proposition B passing and us
having to cancel four academy classes at that point.
That caused us to miss the
recruitment by 280 firefighters that year. By the
time we started recruitment again,
it was 18 months without hiring a single
firefighter. And in that time,
attrition continued. The normal and annual attrition
continued to happen in 2020, we had higher than normal attrition.
So that exacerbated the issue.
Since that time, we've been approved 280
firefighters per year to be hired. This year,
the mayor approved the fifth class, which puts
us at 350 firefighters that we're going to be hiring
this fiscal year. That is, in attempts to
make up for what we lost in 2019 and 2020. Our normal
annual attrition is about 170.
That's retirements, that's resignations. That's everything else
about 170. We're having to hire 100 above
and beyond the normal attrition to try to make up for what we
lost again in 2019 and 2020.
But my most precious resource
is the first year firefighter, because it takes about a year to
get them recruited, to get them trained and get them out into the
stations. So it's a long process, and that's why
it's taken us so long. It's going to take us several fiscal years to make
up what we lost back then. It is
a concern for us. We are making up
that shortage by increasing
our overtime budget numbers in order to
bring in personnel to make up for those
shortages. But the goal is, the strategic goal is to get back
up to full staffing, because at that point, it would allow me to
make the additional ask for more ambulances and more
inspectors and more capacity to be able to service the increased demand.
If you can repeat your have the rating
agencies indicated any concern about the fact that you
are dough as you just described? Doug, is this your second question?
Well, it's related to the question you just answered,
but the second question relates to page
item three four, where you have your performance
measures and you don't have any targets for
first call response for either fire or EMS in 2023.
And then on that same page,
you talk about EMS incidents and responses and
fire incidents and responses, and responses are
a lot higher than the incidents. And I'm just wondering what's
the difference between those two. So the reason for
that, Doug, is we're switching to accreditation measures.
In the past, we were reporting averages.
The average means that half the time you're better, but half the time you're
worse. The accreditation measure now is based
on percentiles. The 90th percentile is what they're
measuring. That gives a better picture
of your capacity and the type
of service you're delivering. That's the reason for that change.
We're also looking at outcome based
responses instead of just simply showing
up in a certain amount
of time and stopping the clock. Again, that's the
reason right now that you're seeing a lot of first
response units, ladder trucks, fire trucks,
when you actually need a medical and EMS transport unit.
We haven't been tracking that appropriately. We're stopping
the clock based on response times without really looking at the outcome.
That is going to provide me the analysis and the tools
to make the case for those additional units that
we desperately need. I know we need more ambulances.
That's the reason that we're sending the first available unit. A lot of times
they show up just to stop the clock and then they're
waiting for that ambulance and transport unit to arrive minutes
later. The answer to that is not
adding more fire trucks. It's adding more ambulance capacity,
which will help the system. It'll improve the response times for
transport and it really will improve the working
environment. Thank you, Chief. And what
about the incidents and response difference between those two?
What are you looking at?
Doug? I'm going to have to get back to you on that. I don't want
to give you an answer off the fly. I got to see exactly what you
are asking about. And Mrs. Smith, if you want to submit any
additional questions to District E at Houst Gov,
we'll get back to you shortly.
I know and I appreciate it. Thank you all. Thank you.
Thank you. We will now move into the in person
public comment period. Public speakers, please make your way to
the podium after your name is called. We have one in
person speaker. Mr. Butler, please come
forward.
Ms. McHenry, if you could please step back
and he will be able to use your microphone and then you can come back.
Thank you.
Good morning. Good morning. You have two minutes for questions.
Thank you. How are you? How are you, chief? Good to see you.
Mr. Brother, good to see you as well. My name is Broderick Butler and I'm
a resident of Cynic Wood neighborhood in northeast Houston,
which is District B. I'd like to thank the Chief for his
leadership. I have a few questions for him, but first a
statement. I want him to thank Al Bennett,
who has made sure that my community has gotten carbon monoxide detectors
and smoke detectors and continues to do so recently.
So my three questions are this. In a previous budget
cycle chief, you mentioned to this committee that you had a significant
number of engines in your fleet that were in disrepair. You were
waiting on new engines, and you were also seeking
to technology, but you're also waiting to seek
more training for your firefighters. You've addressed these points in
some of the questions that were posed to you today. But again,
the theme is, can you reiterate has
any of these issues been addressed at this point? That's the first question.
The second question is, given that you have five incoming classes
queued up, that's great news, but are you currently having
trouble recruiting applicants within the Houston city limits?
If so, what have you done to combat that? And the thought is
about increasing diversity, as one of the council members mentioned.
And so these themes are sort of repetitive themes,
but my last question actually deals with my specific community as
sort of the other ones overlay, and that is we're going
in hurricane season and how many firehouses in Northeast?
Houston, which is sort of north of
610, east of 59. Specifically the seven 70
116 zip code have
water evacuation and water rescue equipment.
And from what I know, the Tidwell
firehouse has one boat. But my question going
forward is, is there a possibility or
opportunity to increase the number of boats or water rescue
equipment and apparatuses that are in my section of the city?
Mr. Weller, thank you, first of all, for your question and for being here in
person. I know that's important.
All this is important to you. So I wrote down your questions.
I will thank albennett is one of our better
employees, and he's very responsive and he's very committed to what he's doing.
So I'll certainly relay your thanks to him
in regards to the engines and disrepair. Five years
ago, five and a half years ago when
I came here, we had an issue with an aging
fleet. There was no question about that. We had engines
that were essentially catching fire on scene.
That was as a result of the
way they were purchasing these units. They're very expensive. A fire
truck cost us about $600,000 per unit.
A ladder truck is over a million dollars. It's very expensive.
They made a large purchase. They had made a large purchase about
15 years before that, and they
didn't have a comprehensive replacement plan, which meant
that you buy a large purchase of fleet vehicles
at one point, and they're great when they're new, but then they all start
aging at the same time and falling apart at the same time.
I'm happy to report that thanks to the mayor and council and their support,
we've replaced over 50% of the entire fleet
in these last five years. We have
a small percentage that now is outside the
ten year expected lifecycle of these heavy
apparatus. We have begun to focus not
only on the heavy apparatus and ambulances, but we
were also focusing on the light duty vehicles, as we mentioned through some other
creative programs, the lease of these vehicles and
outright purchase of these. So we're making a wholesale
replacement of all apparatus. They're all emergency response
apparatus in my estimation. But in regards to
the engines and the ladder trucks, we have made significant
improvements in the state of this fleet. In addition
to that, the ambulance replacements, we've replaced almost 50% of
those ambulances as well. We are
no longer doing the refurbishing and putting them back into
the system. We're buying turnkey ambulances,
which with all the new safety features that
come with the new apparatus. So that's a better
and safer unit for our firefighters. So in
regards to that, yes, we are well over 50% of
replacement of our entire fleet in terms of technology.
We have made significant investments in that too. We've replaced all our
MDTs and the majority of our apparatus.
We've also switched over our records management system for our inspectors.
Now we're in the in four program. In the past, they were doing
their inspections and documenting on paper.
That's very antiquated, very inefficient. We've made significant
improvements in technology in that respect. Every one of our apparatus,
our heavy apparatus, has a thermal imaging camera. Now,
in the past, that was not the case. So we've provided
that in terms of technology. And so I can point to
a variety of areas where we've made improvements in technology training.
Again, sometimes we can't
get the contributions from the general fund
because of different priorities, but we haven't stopped there.
We've looked for nontraditional funding sources to provide for
training and equipment and health and safety aspects for our firefighters.
In the last five and a half years, we've drawn down almost $11 million
of grant funds that are dedicated for either training or
equipment or improvements for health and safety of our firefighters. So we're
making progress in that. In regards to applicants,
especially for applicants from within the city limits, I completely agree
with you. Matter of fact,
in this last month, I've met with the
superintendent for HISD, the vice superintendent
for HISD, and we're looking at a program to be able
to recruit individuals right out of high school.
The requirement for 24 credit hours of
college hasn't changed. But what
we do know is that there are a lot of students, and according to their
numbers, there are about 6000 students every year that graduate with
an equivalent of 24 credit hours that
come from AP classes or come from
other early college courses
that right now we hadn't been capturing. My goal
is to be able to go directly into these communities that are underrepresented
in our department and recruit directly from high school
onto this organization. When they graduate,
they have choices. Some of them go to college, some of
them go to the military, some go to work. I want to be another choice
for those where we can provide a career for these
individuals and they have the opportunity to serve in their communities.
So we are looking at that, and I agree with you. Our department should be
representative of the communities that we serve. That has
been a focus of mine. If you see our demographics,
we've made huge improvements in recruitment of more minorities
into the fire department. And there
we did some things. We made some changes that just increased the number of
qualified applicants. The standards haven't changed.
Okay. But if we can have a bigger pool of applicants,
then we can be more selective as far as who can come in. We're not
having any trouble filling the classes that we have for
the academy. We have had some challenges, especially during
the Pandemic, where we had to do remote learning in classes via virtually,
because getting a certification for an EMT is
not the virtual approach is not conducive to that.
The curriculum is very challenging. They need
the in class tuition, so our
attrition rate there has been higher than normal. We're hoping
that has changed. Council has approved us getting additional resources
and buildings at the train academy to be able to provide that training.
So we're hoping that that changes for the better in
regard to hurricane season and the assets. When I got here in
2017, we had Harvey. We didn't have any high water vehicles.
Matter of fact, we had one, and that was from District A,
and we got that vehicle the day that Harvey made
landfall. Since then, we've made
tremendous progress. Now we have 15 high water
vehicles that are spread out throughout the city.
We've replaced our boats. Those are all serviceable.
We have an 80 member water strike team that is now trained and
equipped and ready to deploy and augment for
these resources for these incidents.
And we've also made partnerships.
We've used our network with other departments to be
able to meet the training requirements and to
be able to scale up if required.
One example is we've partnered with Public
Works. Do you know how many people fit in the
back of a dump truck? 38. Yes, I do.
Yes, sir. And the reason we know that is because we've used those in the
past, but now we've incorporated them into the Cat
system. So if we expect a
hurricane or some inclement weather, we will deploy
resources from Public Works in other areas into our fire stations,
and they'll have a firefighter assigned to them to be able to
manage and be an additional asset in addition to
what we have. So we have made tremendous strides in
that respect as well. In these short five years.
The resources are spread out throughout the city.
Okay. And that is a tactical decision,
but they're deployable anywhere in the city.
Okay. Shift. Absolutely.
One is that we can't put all the resources in one area because
there may not be enough room. But we do know, and based on
what we anticipate, as far as if there's a certain area that we're more
concerned about, then we will shift resources and pre deploy them to
a little bit closer. But those resources are city
of Houston resources, the fire department's resources. It doesn't mean that they belong
to a certain district. We keep them in certain areas,
but we can deploy them and shift as needed. So my
only concern at this point is hopefully the council sees the
benefit of scaling you up compared to the county scaling up
the sheriff's department so that you can actually stand in the breach
if and when and really not if, when the next
natural disaster hits our city that has to deal with water rescue.
Right. Well, look, again,
we welcome those additional resources,
but we are certainly also reaching out to other
response agencies to have a unified
front and in response to our community's needs.
We work very well with the Houston Police Department. We work very well with
the Harris County Sheriff's Department. We work very well with Public
Works and all other city departments.
We have a good network of personnel
that train together.
We're familiar with each other's capabilities and the resources that we can come
to bring to bear in case we need it, because I think
that's a more efficient way of meeting the expected
risk of this community strategic partnership. Absolutely.
And the key is to have those partnerships in place before the
disaster happens. Thank you very much.
If we have any additional questions, you can always share those at District
E, at Houst, gov. Ms.
McHenry, did you have anything additional that you would like to speak on
that we have not covered? Okay. Well, chief, I want to
thank you and your entire department for the tremendous presentation and the tremendous
job you all do on a daily basis to keep Houstonian safe.
As a council, we are very much appreciative of
all that you do and all of the contributions that you make. So to you
and your entire team, thank you very much. Thank you.
Council Member there are no additional in person speakers before
we adjourn. Please note, budget workshops will continue next
week, starting Monday, May 16 through Thursday,
May 19. Reminder to council members to be checking SharePoint for
uploaded presentations as well as responses for any questions and
submitted. Thank you again to everyone for being here, and this
meeting is adjourned.